hmm
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is that it
all right i'm scared right now cam
newton is a giant human being
uh a six foot five inch frame peter on
top of that and for those of you who are
listening on radio or podcast cam
newton's workout video that he posted
yesterday shirtless i mean to be that to
have that kind of a build that v
that thickness on a six foot five inch
frame are you kidding me i don't know
what's up with his foot i don't know
what's up with his shoulder but i'll
tell you what the guy continues to be
one of the most impressive physical
specimens i've ever seen in my life
peter king
yeah i mean
it's that's a nice video and obviously
it shows that he's working out but what
does it mean i mean really
and again it's true that's the first
that's the first time that i saw that so
was it part of a 20-minute something
that's available somewhere i you know i
don't know my only point about this is
we've talked about this a lot on this
show mike and that is until
cam newton undergoes a lot of physical
testing by a team you know and not by
just an independent uh uh physician in
my opinion until he undergoes a a a a
thorough examination of both his foot
his shoulder and everything
and until
somebody has a long conversation with
him about hey look we have a starting
quarterback here we're not sure we're
not positive you're going to be a
starter how do you how does that fit
with you and maybe he just says because
mike you know the smartest thing for cam
newton is do nothing until august 20th
someone's going to call you on august
20th because they're going to need a
quarterback desperately and you're going
to go in and by october 1st you'll know
everything and you'll be the starter on
that team and maybe even before that
maybe even opening day but
i just think
he is a different case and everybody
says how can he not be signed he can't
be signed because he's got a lot of
question marks around him right now and
i think those have to be answered before
i throw a lot of money at him
you know when you talk about cam newton
peter i i get the impression that you
think there is no clear starting job for
him out there anywhere i think the
chargers again if you can check him out
and give him your own physical not that
bogus on the way out the door carolina
panthers physical that they wanted him
to pass and he wanted to pass that means
nothing as it relates to the physical
that will be administered by a team that
may sign him if he can pass that
physical is he not an immediate upgrade
over tyrod taylor for two reasons one
football two
business and the business is every bit
as important when you're opening a new
stadium and you can't fill it up with
your own fans
i agree mike i totally agree
all i know is that everybody who knows
anthony lynn
tells me that he and he's not just
saying this
that
he not only is going forward with uh
tyrod taylor but he's excited about
going forward with tyrod taylor so
i'm not arguing with you tyrod taylor is
not better than cam newton we know that
but tyrod taylor knows this offense he
knows this team he knows his people
in what is sure to be a very abbreviated
off-season
anthony lynn looks at it in my opinion
and this might change but i think he
looks at it and he says this guy who we
know
and who's been in our system gives us a
better chance this year
than the guy who we don't know who's
going to have a very abbreviated
off-season with us so that's that's the
logic there i'm not saying that it's the
smartest decision i'm saying that's what
i believe anthony lynn is thinking
read into this what you will but tyrod
taylor recently posted a video of him
working out with cam newton so look
tyrod taylor has been a guy who uh is a
starter and then he's benched and then
he's passed around here and he's passed
around there traded from the bills to
the browns and then the browns are done
with him he goes to the chargers and and
the guy has has had a decent career
i just
firmly believe that if cam newton's
healthy he's one of the top 10
quarterbacks in the nfl which would put
him ahead of tyrod taylor let me ask you
this peter because i saw stephen a smith
make this argument the other day and i
usually disagree with pretty much
everything stephen a smith says but he's
right on this one
the panthers held on to cam newton for
so long that it complicated his ability
to land somewhere else and i know what
the panthers were doing right think back
to early february right after the super
bowl they released greg olsen no
questions asked he's free and clear he's
able to go sign with another team he
lands with the seahawks well before free
agency begins they kept cam newton why
did they keep cam newton the message was
we want cam newton and if you want cam
newton you're going to have to trade
something to us to get him and they they
held on to that hope of getting
something for cam newton for so long
that by the time they set him free most
of the seats are taken he's got limited
options can't have a proper physical do
you think the panthers should have
handled cam newton differently
you could argue that maybe they should
have but to me
the the reason that the panthers did
this is they thought all along somebody
would give a four for cam newton or
maybe even a three it's what the
cincinnati bengals are doing right now
with andy dalton they know that they're
not gonna have andy dalton on their team
okay i mean they should know uh joe
burrows gonna be their quarterback
but but they're not releasing them
because they want somebody bill
belichick uh you know dave caldwell and
jacksonville they want somebody to give
a three or a four
for uh for andy dalton and i don't think
anybody is going to do that so you try
to do what you can is anybody going to
give anything for greg olsen i doubt it
sincerely
you know he's old he's been hurt a lot
he's flirting with tv why would you give
up something if he's on the street maybe
we'll take him and we'll see what
happens cam newton is a different story
and so i i would have done what carolina
did even though it's probably unfair to
cam newton
and here's the thing you know they had
the right to do it that doesn't make it
right per se but this is one of the
reasons why it's important to build into
these contracts a trigger that forces a
team to make an early decision that's
why todd gurley was cut last thursday by
the rams and i'm still astounded there
are people who think that todd gurley
was mistreated he got 46 million dollars
over five years if they hadn't signed
him to a second 49 49 million 49 million
he would have gotten he would have
gotten he would have gotten 23 million
if they had treated him the way the
chargers treated melvin gordon by never
giving him a second contract the point
is this you put the devices in the
contracts every year not just the first
two or three
every year peter five million dollar
roster bonus due the third day of the
league year or do the third day of the
waiver period you can build these things
into the out years of a contract most
agents i think assume that by the time
we get to year four five six it's going
to be ripped up anyway you can't assume
that you've got to get those clauses in
there and if there had been a five
million dollar balloon payment or a full
guarantee of his full salary for this
year that came due on the third day of
the waiver period in february he'd have
been cut right along with with greg
olsen so there's a lesson here
understand that teams are going to do
things that we're going to look at from
time to time and say well that kind of
sucks that they're treating a guy this
way you plan for it by stacking the deck
in the contract to force the team to
make a decision if andy dalton had that
in the last year of his contract with
the bengals right now and i think he's
only signed for one more year possibly
two i think it's one but if he had that
language that would have made if he
would if it would have made the salary
guaranteed by the first day of the
league year he'd have been cut a long
time ago and and so you know look we can
say that the panthers should have
treated cam newton better we can say the
bengals should be treating andy dalton
better the bottom line is there's a way
to counter this you build it into the
contract to force the team to make a
decision early
you should have been an agent
no thank you no thank you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports